[Music]
predicting the future can be tricky
some things are clear like the cycle of
the sun or the punchline of a joke
[Music]
other things are less predictable like
who will be elected a country's next
leader
[Music]
but before every election a group of
people try to forecast the future
they're the soothsayers of politics the
pollsters
while their successes fill headlines
if they get it wrong their failures do
too if this exit poll is right andrew i
will publicly eat my hat
no matter how well a poll is conducted
there will always be uncertainty
so what's the best way to predict an
election
[Music]
elections are at the heart of modern
democracies
and one country has played a crucial
role in shaping the culture around them
from the first time an election was held
here people were trying to predict what
might happen
and they bet their bottom dollar on it
in the 1800s and 1900s election betting
was a huge market and the odds were a
good indicator of who would win
but newspapers developed a better way to
predict what might happen
they asked people
but these first polls known as straw
polls were pretty flawed they only
sampled the people who happened to be
nearby the reporter so these polls
fourth of july celebrations and meetings
of local militia members weren't
representative of the country as a whole
straw polls were basically guesswork but
by 1936 one man was keen to improve them
george gallup
in the presidential race that year he
pit his method against a major straw
pollster the literary digest
the digest used car registration lists
and telephone directories to find people
to survey so their sample was skewed
towards the wealthy
gallup's method relied on interviewing
voters at random and was more
representative of the electorate
the digest predicted a win for alf
landing while gallup's results pointed
to
roosevelt despite gallup's pole being
much smaller than the digests
gallup was right
gallup's success in 1936 laid the
groundwork for how polls are conducted
today
[Music]
today hundreds of scientific polls like
gallups are taken for any given election
so how do they work
the first critical part of polling is to
get a sample that looks like the
population that means hitting the right
quotas in terms of demographics of age
gender education social class
if 50 of a population were female for
example
50 percent of the people polled also
need to be female
when that logic is applied to things
like education and age you get a pretty
good sample
you then need to ask that sample a
question
the wording and poll questions can vary
a little bit but
on one level it's incredibly simple if
they're an election tomorrow how would
you vote
it's the same the world over
an election
having a good sample and simple question
is the key to an unbiased poll
but once they have the answers there are
more adjustments pollsters need to do
one key issue that we have with polls is
they tend to be responded to by people
who are politically engaged
pollsters use all sorts of adjustments
to try and make the people
who answer those surveys look a little
bit more like the electorate
for example if they know educated people
are more likely to vote they bump up how
much their answer is worth
so a lot of work goes into making sure a
poll hits the mark
[Music]
but they are not flawless
never has that been more evident than in
the 2016 us presidential election
most of the polls claimed hillary
clinton would win
but when the final result came in
many were shocked
donald trump won states where he had
never been ahead in any poll taken by
any polling agency
so what went wrong
the 2016 u.s presidential election is
actually a great example of the
challenges of polling and how we
interpret polling errors if you look at
the national polls in the election they
weren't actually that bad they were a
couple of points out which was pretty
much in line with historical average
you know hillary clinton actually won
the national popular votes right
right indeed
national polls said hillary clinton
would win 52.3 percent of votes cast for
either democrats or republicans
she actually won 51.1
so there was an error of 1.2 points in
favor of clinton
and that error was actually pretty small
historically polls have had a much
larger margin for error this close to an
election
what really happened in 2016 is that the
state polls were off in states like
michigan wisconsin and pennsylvania the
states that were closest and would have
given hillary clinton the electoral
votes to put her over the top polls were
much more biased than they were
nationally in the competitive states
that cost clinton the election some
polls were up to 10 points off
these errors were partly down to flawed
methodology
the inquiry into the the election polls
found that the state level polls in the
midwest weren't getting enough
non-college graduates the sort of people
that were absolutely critical to the
donald trump coalition and so that's a
really great example about why getting
the right sample and the sample that
looks like the electorate on election
day is absolutely critical for the
reliability of opinion polls
another complication was that many
voters didn't make their decision until
the final week
so polls didn't pick up on people who
decided to vote for trump late in the
game
polls become more predictive as the
election gets nearer simply because
people are making up their minds their
preference is crystallized there are
some people for whom they always know
how they're going to vote but for a good
number of voters they're making up their
mind as they go along
if only american pollsters had known
that in 1948
they were so sure that thomas dewey
would win the presidential race that
they stopped polling a few weeks before
the election
even the weather seems to be against
president truman but that can't shake
his confidence any more than do the
opinion polls which rate him no chance
the chicago tribune newspaper even
printed their front cover declaring a
dewey victory
quite a faux pas when truman won
[Music]
so if we can't expect poles to make
laser-like predictions
what can you do
well you can make a statistical model
models look back in time to examine why
people voted the way they did
and apply the logic of those outcomes to
what might happen in the future
our study of historical elections has
found that averaging bulls together and
exploring their
margins for error on average
gives people a better understanding of
the electoral horse race there are two
types of models we make one that
examines polls alone
and one based on polling and other
factors like the state of the country's
economy or a candidate's funding
statisticians call these factors
fundamentals
a fundamentals based approach to
election prediction might say economic
growth means higher support for the
incumbent
lower unemployment means higher support
for the incumbent
in doing this it's actually possible to
predict an election quite accurately
without looking at any polling at all
take the 1992 presidential race in
america the polls were all over the
place
but a fundamentals-based projection
proved much more accurate
but when polling in a country is good or
there isn't a lot of historical data on
fundamentals a model based only on the
polls works well
that's our approach to the 2022 french
presidential election
[Music]
there are two rounds of voting in this
race so making a model for it is a bit
complicated
our model has to explore uncertainty for
both rounds separately and average the
poles for both rounds separately and
then combine them in a sort of
chained step-by-step forecasting model
first we look into what the polls say we
examine every poll for every candidate
on any given day
and use a fancy statistical tool called
a spline to find an average
this is far more reliable than any
individual poll
then we analyze historical polling data
to quantify how reliable french polls
are
these dots show the margin of error in
every election poll since 1965.
an average can then be taken
for example 100 days before the election
the polls are usually about four points
off the end result
we then run simulations on different
outcomes based on how a candidate is
polling on a certain day running up to
the election
these simulations may have different
winners every time but the more times a
candidate wins then the greater the
probability that they'll win in real
life
so that gives us different simulated
french elections with different winners
and we used that set of winners to
calculate the probability that any one
candidate would win the presidency
on february 5th 2022 roughly 10 weeks
before the french presidential election
emmanuel macron made it to round two 92
times out of a hundred
marine le pen did 48 times in 100.
so the odds were that voters in round
two would be choosing between macron and
le pen
in that match-up macron won 88 of the
time
we had to run 10 million different
election simulations in order to come up
with our eventual prediction
two months before the election the
probability of a victory for macron was
around 80 percent
that might seem high but it's about the
same chance that a footballer scores a
penalty kick
[Applause]
and they often miss
it's important for readers to think
about our predictions not as final
100 predictions of an outcome but as
exploring a range of potential outcomes
for an election it's important to
remember that
unforeseen election outcomes happen
all the time
models are only as reliable as the polls
that go into them
and when elections occur during extreme
events like a pandemic or a war then
anything can happen
but as times go on and with more
historical data available
election modeling should improve
it's theoretically impossible to have a
100 accurate election forecast we would
have to get massively lucky to do that
but we're not trying to do that what
we're trying to do is use data and
statistics to get pretty close
[Music]
if you'd like to read more about the
methodology behind our election
forecasts click the link we also make
the source code for our models freely
available you can find that link in the
description below thanks for watching
and don't forget to subscribe